[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya plusieurs de gironde à une dizaine
justement représenté nos militants qui
se battent tous les jours sur le terrain
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est très
important qu'on se réunisse c'est
l'occasion de poser les bases d'une
nouvelle équipe avec un nouvel esprit de
rassemblement
l'engagement la confrontation des idées
c'est aux républicains qui le soutient
et c'est cette démonstration que nous
devons faire cette capacité de
résistance et cette capacité à porter un
projet d'alternance sont venus
spécialement de mayotte une grosse
délégation
parce qu'après tout c'est un moment pour
la fin on est heureux de travailler tous
ensemble et faire voir que les
républicains sont bien là bien présent
et bien vivant merci à vous tous chers
conseillers nationaux parce que dans
chacune de vos fédérations
vous vous êtes mobilisés pour faire de
ce rendez vous un moment de démocratie
avec les élections municipales et les
investitures qui se décident les
soutiens c'était important qu'on se
regroupe qu'on se retrouve tous en
famille pour parler d'une même voix
le but c'est de relancer la machine et
surtout d'être vainqueur ou aux
municipales qu'on a beaucoup changé sur
les idées de manière à ce que soit une
alternative finalement à ce qui se passe
à ce que et maintenant que l'on voudrait
installer si vous êtes là encore ici
aujourd'hui si nous sommes là c'est
parce que nous croyons que la droite n'a
pas vocation à devenir ni l'arrière
boutique de la macro ni ni l'arrière
boutique de marion maréchal-le pen
notre conviction si nous sommes là
encore aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous
pensons que nous devons exister par nous
mêmes
j'ai bien apprécié des
questions-réponses compte
j'ai beaucoup apprécié la nouvelle
méthode de travail elle donne beaucoup
plus la parole aux militants que nous
sommes tous avant d'être conseillé aux
autres forces sur ce discours là que
christian jacob s'est fait élire
vraiment un échange à l'enrichissement
mutuel parce qu'après tout il faut
écouter à base militants c'est pour ça
qu'on est là je pense que les forums
thématiques c'est une bonne idée
la droite elle gagne quand on s'adresse
à tous les français
sur tous les sujets c'est d'être capable
sur l'autorité sur le travail sur la
solidarité sur le droit de propriété qui
est sans cesse bafoués aussi sur le
poids de la dépense publique et de la
fiscalité de se retrouver sur quelques
messages de foncer nous sommes en mesure
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent d'incarner le travail la
laïcité les territoires et toutes les
thématiques évoquées
de manière évidente les français se
retourneront à nouveau ouverte qu'à une
volonté de donner la parole
effectivement au territoire
il ya une volonté de rajeunissement du
parti ce qui est très important
christian jacob a vraiment à coeur de
relancer le mouvement des jeunes annonce
un vrai budget qui nous sera déléguée
pour pouvoir mener des actions sur le
territoire
c'est complètement satisfait évidemment
je veux vraiment qu'on incarne la
jeunesse et pour incarner la jeunesse eh
bien il faut avoir le courage de laisser
de la place spontanéité générosité
humanisme je pense que c'est vraiment ce
qui caractérise le plus notre parti
[Musique]